I want to play a little game that I am
calling I call out that Queen okay I'm
gonna run through certain descriptors
mm-hmm and some might be compliments
some might be constructive criticism or
read or reads and you can interpret the
words and the terms in any way you want
to okay and you just name which of your
season ten sisters most applies either
way alright well start with dirtiest
don't oh my gosh dirtiest the Vixen her
station was always a mess and then
messiest where there's so many messiest
I'd have to say Eureka I know that
sometimes I am a lot to deal with them
okay thirstiest thirstiest Eureka please
just thinks she's funny
but oh gosh
myself Asia I said so many things I
thought were hilarious and then they
play them and everybody's like crickets
something definitely me I'm just joking
just joking doesn't know she's funny it
doesn't know she's funny aquaria wait
y'all gonna know is really truly funny
it's really truly funny monique art
facts of that thrifty estonia cards we
saw her pulling it out lights out
do not get me started I came to this
competition with glitter in Jesus and
[ __ ] I'm making it work okay
never love Joe fishes fishes Blair
Sinclair well I do declare walking away
from the experience who is your sister
for life Cameron Michaels camera
microphone I say it about me but I
admire her as a person to so much and
she is probably the only girl from this
season I would say I am a true fan of in
life like I would be thrilled if she won
I have no idea who the winner is I would
be the one on the front row saying yes
girl
you deserve it [ __ ] so so I'm told who
the winner is
then I'll celebrate
[Applause]